this is as our dear president dr. Arnn
usually says a terrible and glorious
time to be alive the technology that has
improved the human condition is a
tremendous blessing to us all men and
women of great skill have dreamt of
things that were formerly thought
impossible and made them part of our
everyday lives
however with the new industry with new
industry typically comes as we know very
well here at Hillsdale and ever-growing
bureaucracy searching for things to
regulate the energy industry certainly
falls under this category just as new
methods of producing energy come online
there is always an extreme environmental
group or friendly government
administrator there to delay it or if
possible destroy it of course we know
there must be laws that set a framework
for free markets but in order to
maintain our free Republic the framework
must adhere to constitutionalism and the
will of the sovereign part of hills
dales motto is to is to pursue truth
energy perhaps more than any other
industry or area of public policy is
plagued with half-truths extremism
inconvenient truths and of course
flat-out lies we gather here at this
second CCA seminar this year which is
co-sponsored by the ludwig von mises
lecture series to explore these issues
and further the mission of Hillsdale
College I welcome you here with us it is
an honor for me to be with you and I
look forward to learning with you our
student introducer tonight is Mary Koren
who is majoring in philosophy she is a
senior and hails from fountain Colorado
Mary
good afternoon it's an honor to
introduce to you our first speaker dr.
Peter Grossman oh sorry
dr. Peter Grossman is the Clarence
Ephraim's and professor of economics at
Butler University dr. Grossman received
his bachelor's and philosophy from
Columbia University and his master's in
PhD in economics from Washington
University he has written for numerous
publications including the Indianapolis
Star The Wall Street Journal the
Christian Science Monitor the Cato
journal energy policy and the Journal of
Public Policy he is co-author of
introduction to energy and co-editor and
principal author of the end of a natural
monopolies deregulation and competition
in the electric power industry his most
recent book is US energy policy and the
pursuit of failure which is named the
energy book of the Year by powerline so
if you all join me in giving a warm
welcome to our speaker dr. Grossman
so is this water from a button and you
pronounce T from sin correctly one of
the few people to do so first of all let
me thank Hillsdale and all of the people
connected with the Center for
constructive alternatives for inviting
me I appreciate the opportunity I
appreciate the opportunity and it's a
pleasure to see what kind of program
you've put together which i think is
quite going to be quite an illuminating
few days my talk is called a history of
energy regulation in the US I've
subtitled it a dismal scientist examines
a dismal subject but let me start by my
talk this way to score and one years ago
our fathers and mothers brought forth
new energy policies conceived in a panic
and dedicated to a proposition no it can
really define well if you need a model
for a speech why not a classic but in
any case I get ahead of my story by
talking about the 1970s which is what I
was referring to there so let's step
back to the post-civil war era as energy
resources became more central to u.s.
industrial production in fact to every
individual
it was then probably inevitable that
energy would and would invite government
scrutiny when the Supreme Court ruled in
1877 that government could regulate
activities that were affected with the
public interest the growing energy
industry was soon to be affected with
political interests that might be better
to say in fact that energy industries
soon became afflicted with the public
interest or with the political interest
though we're determined to gain control
over energy
sources that affliction has at times
been so disruptive that energy markets
that we have that energy to energy
markets that we've been left sitting in
the cold waiting for fuel US regulation
of energy has been an adventure an
adventure without a clear destination
nor often even a rationale an adventure
that persists as government even now
seeks to make the extraction delivery
and consumption of resources that have
made this country so extraordinarily
successful to remake it friends that are
at best ambiguous and means that are
both ill suited to the task and beyond
the understanding of most of the
politicians who promote them as a
consequence there have been there has
been much regulation that has been
costly and foolish that will surprise no
one here a government Quixote is faced
with voter demands that they do
something whenever there's something
inconvenient like an oil price spike and
struck by lobbying group glue lobbying
groups claims have gone from tilting at
windmills to tilting with windmills
tilting against evildoers such as rich
oil companies and frackers all in cause
of saving a world that doesn't really
need saving that of course is the story
of what happened with respect to
government to energy policies and I will
address the what and its corresponding
question when in the course of my talk
today but there's the third question why
why is government imposed regulations on
energy markets however badly it turned
out what was it supposed to accomplish
what has been the rationale in the past
and what in fact is the rationale today
I should say at the outset and I may be
in the minority here I believe there can
be arguments for some limited government
interventions and energy markets
and not every government act has had
only negative consequences but energy
regulation generally has had such
ill-defined ends and often incoherent
means to them that some of the time when
something useful seems to occur it
almost appears that because it's
accidental isn't you mean that actually
worked it's my contention in fact that
the most consequential acts of the
federal government at least with respect
to energy occurred in the 1980s when a
significant amount of regulation was
repealed for the most part undoing by
government has been far more productive
than doing well there been some specific
reasons for regulation of the various
energy resources or industries over the
years the one overriding argument for it
has been market failure a government
must step in because markets left alone
will not get either the right price or
the right quantity of a resource or a
service the market leaves out costs the
government sees missus missus benefits
there for the taking distributes
benefits unfairly and allows one firm to
prey on others so then a good regulatory
regime will make it right right not
quite in some sense I have to admit let
me step back again and say the market
failure argument is correct as Ronald
Coase once said markets are more or less
failures the neoclassical model of an
unfailing is impossible it's what harold
deficits called the near vana model
requiring characteristics that don't
exist in the real world but Coast
pointed out that alternatives to markets
firms and government are also failures
what he advocated was to choose the form
of organization that failed least in a
given situation explicitly not to assume
that because there's a market failure
government control would lead to a
better
in this most cases as Hayek observed
efficiency is thwarted in government
even when policymakers are truly
dedicated to the public interest
whatever that means by the knowledge
problem social planners simply cannot
process the vast amounts of information
revealed in markets often without
participants even having an ability to
articulate the various aspects of
personal choice that went into market
transactions so just what are the market
failures that government has thought it
had to correct with respect to energy
there v monopolized markets external
costs particularly pollution external
benefits that entrepreneurs couldn't
appropriate if they invested their own
money public goods that people won't pay
for or pay enough for since they get the
benefits anyway and finally and most
notably poor information especially the
information that should lead to
forward-looking investments this last
one has often been invoked by government
and it means according to policymakers
that markets have lacked foresight
market fails to see and account for what
is said to be obvious for example
throughout the twentieth century and in
the 1970s in particular it was obvious
to all but the deluded that we were
running quickly running out of oil and
natural gas and it was therefore obvious
that also large-scale synthetic fuel
plants solar wind and whatever else was
the technology du jour would be needed
quickly to meet the demand for energy in
the ensuing decade or how about with
electric power in the post-war era for
twenty years it had grown a demand had
grown by 7% per year so surely that
meant who would do so again but that
meant that we would have to have twice
as much as
electric power generation in the next
decade so if there were 4,000 power
plants we would need to build another
4,000 power plants in 10 years meaning
400 per year or one every 22 hours the
thing is we heard things like that back
in the 1970s when such things were
expressed it was clear to policymakers
that most utility in most of the
utilities were not getting ready for
these farsighted facts of the four facts
that the government claimed to see they
worse they were using still using fossil
fuels which except for coal was running
out or were running out and that led to
a regulatory ban on new natural gas or
oil fired electric generating stations
meaning one rule though made it harder
to solve the problem the other one was
supposed to be creating but by the 1980s
it was clear that a funny thing happened
on the way to the market failure price
of fossil fuels had gone up and people
used less utilities that had had
listened to the policymakers found they
had overbuilt and had a lot more
financial trouble than those that had
followed the signals the market was
giving the trend of 7% per year was
unsustainable and it stopped as all
unsustainable trends do without the
government's help in reality I believe
that presidents from Nixon to Obama and
Congress's from the 93rd to 113th I've
had the energy story especially with
respect to so-called energy crises
they've had this story backwards not a
single one of the many events called
energy crises and it's
something you hear endlessly I in the
first decade of the 21st century it was
said 2500 times in Congress that we had
an energy crisis going on but not one of
the many events that have been called
energy crises has ever been solved by
government action though politicians
bluster about this need or that goal
whenever oil prices spiked or there's a
spot shortage of some fuel the market if
allowed to has always solve the problem
prices rise people use less prices fault
a spot shortage say of natural gas
prices rise an incentive to put more gas
into the pipeline oil price spikes gas
or electricity shortages these are
different from even related things like
pollution the Cuyahoga River which in
1969 famously caught fire probably was
not going to clean itself up but markets
in energy given some time and freedom
adjust on their own how did we get into
this place this place of mistaken
notions about what government should do
and what it could do with respect to
energy I think it's instructive as we
move through the history of energy
regulation and government intrusion into
energy markets to consider briefly the
history of each energy resource
separately at least until the 1970s in
fact before the 70s and the first
national energy energy crisis there was
no energy policy because energy
resources were not considered the same
they were considered separate fuels and
separate markets and in distinctly
different markets and that's still true
today but somehow we always are lumping
them together there was talk about a
unified fuels policy John Kennedy talked
about that but there wasn't one but
there was
certainly government intrusion and
regulation of each primary fuel as well
as a major secondary energy production
of electricity
most of those intrusions justified by
market failure with oil the federal
government some market failures
everywhere monopolies lack of foresight
and public goods especially with respect
to national security in 1909 the Taft
administration said oil deposits on
federal lands had to be left in place so
that our ships would have fuel in time
of war of course one could ask why would
that why would there have been a problem
getting fuel well because you see in
1909
we were already running close to the end
of our oil supplies something the market
just wouldn't take seriously according
to the 1908 US Geological Survey there
were a maximum of twenty three billion
barrels of oil left in the United States
about ten years later the u.s. same USGS
said we'd run out of oil in by 1929
somehow we have reserves today of
twenty-nine billion barrels and that's
only known deposits not what else may be
discovered even though we've consumed
far more than 23 million billion barrels
of domestic oil in the last hundred
years but while we were waiting for oil
to disappear and this was this is kind
of the way regulatory system the system
has worked well we waited for oil to
disappear which was going to happen soon
the oil monopolies had to be broken up
presumably to make an oil market that
was supposed soon to vanish to be more
competitive other regulate of your other
regulations at the state level
especially kept coming to this market
said to be on the verge of
extinction for example two types of of
contractual arrangements were that made
oil production more efficient were
outlawed in several states especially in
Texas and there was a great irony in the
way the monopolies argument played out
in the 1930s there was a tremendous glut
of oil and the oil companies were having
trouble making money the solution and
devised and endorsed by both state and
national levels was the creation of an
oil cartel when we think of the oil
cartels we think of OPEC but the first
one that we were really faced with was
one that was a government creation in
the US this cartel was to be it was
administered to be by the Texas Railroad
Commission designed to prop up prices
and control output it managed much of
America's oil market 40 years but think
about this for a minute the answer to
the problem of market failure from
monopoly was to create in effect what
was a monopoly since the cartel is
supposed to act like a single firm but
of course this monopoly would be under
the benevolent hand of government but
even that wasn't the whole of the
intrusions into the oil market in 1959
for national security reasons reasons
that no one could actually ever explain
the u.s. imposed a quote on imported oil
this quota called the mandatory oil
import program or Moya was a mess from
the start where everyone and his
grandmother was asking for exceptions it
added another layer of government
oversight which eliminated any semblance
of a free market and oil it was amused
to find someone saying in the early
1980s that Ronald Reagan has taken us
back to the free market in oil I was
thinking he take us back to 1870
natural-gas had by the 1970s an even
greater degree of government control a
natural gas is a major fuel source was a
relatively new phenomenon until the
1920s only cities close to gas fields
had access to natural gas most of which
was found in association with oil and
was considered a nuisance who was FLIR
flared off was burned in fact really to
this day a lot of natural gases is
burned I think something on the order of
700 million cubic feet a day if I'm not
mistaken is flared off because it can't
be piped but once pipelines began to
carry natural gas from gas fields to
consumers there is concern that the
pipeline's were so-called natural
monopolies because of pervasive
economies of scale I have a book about
natural monopolies and my one of the
chapters that I wrote was that that most
monopolies are natural monopolies are
not naturally monopolies but and I'll
have more to say about it when I talk
about electricity but in theory a big
pipeline has a much greater volume than
a smaller pipeline and should be able to
underprice any smaller pipeline
companies so making sure that pipelines
gave equal access to gas production and
gas producers might have made some sense
as a regulatory move but that was hardly
where it ended through a series of laws
notably the federal natural gas act of
1938 as well as interpretations by the
regulatory body over it the Deaf edirol
Power Commissioner and the courts so
that by the mid 1950s the FPC was
empowered not just to control access to
pipelines that crossed state lines but
also set the wholesale price for all
interstate gas from the pipelines and
after 1954 the price of natural gas
front destined for Interstate mark mark
interstate markets at the wellhead
of course the distribution of natural
gas locally was controlled by either
state groups and municipal authorities
very often so the regulation and
intrusion government authorities the
level of regulation and intrusion into
national natural gas was complete from
wellhead producer to final consumer it's
not just regulated who was entirely
controlled by various government
entities even before the energy crisis
of the 1970s there was a belief that
natural gas production in the US had
peaked and would soon be gone or as
Jimmy Carter's Deputy Secretary of
Energy put it in 1976 natural gas has
had it and but why would people look for
guess when regardless of supply or
demand the price was going to be fixed
by the government
electricity mm-hmm electricity had also
of course become a creature of
government it was always regulated to
some extent since municipalities had to
grant special franchises to firms the
wanted to put their wires along public
streets but for the most part from the
1880s until the early 1900's the
industry is competitive because
franchisees franchises were granted to
local generators sometimes granted to
those who offered very good sized bribes
but hey they were often extra costs of
doing business then some producers
abetted by a few economists notably
Richard Ely use the natural monopolies
argument that only one producers should
serve a given area since eventually only
one can survive pervasive economies of
scale and electrical generating and and
so on
but that was not what was actually
happening competition was common and the
cost of electric power to consumers fell
significantly in some places
the US competition actually persisted
and benefited consumers throughout the
20th century the largest electric
companies led by Samuel insoles Chicago
Edison however called all of that
competition ruinous that is it reduced
his profits but of course if electric
companies really were natural monopolies
they should have been should have
quickly been reduced to a single large
firm anyway and competition should only
have been ruinous to small interlopers
the large companies well-connected in
many cases persuaded the states to take
over the regulatory process whereby the
basic system that we've become familiar
with over the years whereby one firm
would be given monopoly control over a
particular area charging a regulated
price that reflected a fair of fair
return on capitals as determined by the
Commission by the early 1910s that
argument had won the day and prices for
consumers as jor-el noted promptly rose
the natural monopolies argument
persisted and regulation was mainly the
job of supposedly disinterested
technocrats on public utility
Commission's Commission's that endorsed
increases in rates pretty much whenever
firms asked for them at least until the
1970s when requests became gigantic to
cover nuclear power cost overruns there
was of course also cold chronically
failing Riven with labor strife yet
still vital to electric power generation
and many industrial processes I and
these call to was regulated in labor
practices in environmental practices and
there was also nuclear power which was
embraced by politicians as a way to make
having dropped atom bombs on Nagasaki
and Hiroshima okay
it was called atoms for peace but the
technology was rushed to market before
it was ready and soon seemed like a
million multi-billion dollar white
elephant as it was described in the
1980s so to sum up on the eve of the
first US energy crisis in 1973 America's
energy industries were comprised of a
government controlled oil cartel a
natural gas industry completely under
government control elect an electricity
industry that had made good use of
regulators a failing coal industry and
an over touted overly expensive nuclear
industry
I haven't uncovered a free market in any
of these now here it is the early 1970s
and add another area of regulatory
control to the mix in 1971 Richard I am
now a I am a Keynesian now Nixon imposed
wage and price controls to curb
inflation and while controls on many
things were phased in and out over the
next couple years controls on the price
of oil and oil products stuck by this
time all of these controls had led to
declining oil as well as natural gas
production which was interpreted however
as you see now we can see that we're
running out but the energy crisis
changed the picture in a number of ways
and none of them for the good
it led first it controls on quantities
as well as prices it produced an
burgeoning energy bureaucracy first the
Federal Energy administration which I
believe had 3,000 employees in its first
incarnation and then later the
Department of Energy which had 20,000
employees in Congress where there had
only been a few committees that had any
involvement in energy soon there were
over 30 what
perhaps worst and most pernicious of all
it led to a story a fiction about what
the energy crisis had been about and
therefore what we needed to do about it
in 1970 the 1970s energy crisis
narrative went like this
we were now dependent on a world oil
market well that much was true
we had to import oil to meet demand
although in 1973 if the price was too
high we had to get government approval
so whether more oil was imported it or
not depended in part on the cost of
living Council and later the Federal
Energy administration and they told
companies what they could charge how
much they could raise their prices but
the rest of the energy crisis narrative
was a fiction the crisis had begun with
the Arab oil embargo in response to US
support for Israel in the 1973 Yom
Kippur War the Arab countries wanted to
punish us for that support from the
standpoint of the Arabs the embargo is a
total fiasco the US public became more
pro-israel and and specifically anti
Arab oil producers besides it turned out
that oil producers were far more
dependent on selling their oil than we
were on buying it of course there were
the famous gas lines shortages misery a
lot of us remember that that was the
embargoes fault right
no the misery was due to our own
governments price and then allocation
controls that prevented the market from
clearing the US controls were in
miniature the system that produced the
shortage of economies of the Soviet
Eastern Europe bloc but in our own
narrative we were going to be put
through oil blackmail repeatedly sitting
in cold with gas lines until we changed
our policies
we neither wind up impoverished or doing
the bidding of Arab oil sheiks one
senator said what we're saying now is we
sit at your feet we do your bidding
etc etc but and of course also since the
end of domestic oil was at hand
the impact of future embargoes would be
much worse our sovereignty and our way
of life was said to be at stake the
answer to this story was not the free
market which actually would have been a
good answer it was energy independence
an idea that meant different things to
different people and in fact meant
pretty much nothing at all when it you
finally added it all up at least nothing
that made sense is the national policy
I've counted at least a dozen different
definitions of what energy independence
meant even in this century the narrative
and its attendant solution energy
independence has persisted it was never
the narrative was never true energy
independence was never a rational
response but policymakers have never
been able to get past it in the 1970s of
course things got when far downhill and
in the wrong direction in the 70s there
are 29 separate bills that had layers
upon layers of new regulations and
started the quixotic efforts of
government-sponsored technology panaceas
that was how we were gonna get to be
energy independent well invent something
if we could put a man on the moon we
could well we could put a man on the
moon but I haven't seen that we've
developed lunar tourism and whereas what
they're talking about is developing some
commercial enterprise but the
government-sponsored technology panaceas
of the of the 70s included breeder
reactors syn fuels
and my favorite a bill to require
scientists to create a nuclear fusion
power plant by the year 2001 according
to Jim Wright and the House of
Representatives passage of this bill was
going to be the catalyst for the second
creation of fire
no hubris in the in Congress Robert
Higgs has pointed out that government
always grows in a crisis bills are
passed and not repealed agencies are
created that only grow and seek to
expand their budgets and their authority
some of the more fundamentally useless
efforts in the last 40 years have been
reversed syn fuels and a few other
things and most importantly the controls
on prices and quantities have been
repealed but at most of the bills that
were passed the last 40 years remain on
the books and have come back to bite us
the production tax credit for wind for
example was passed in 1992 a bill that
was considered to be almost nothing but
it stayed on the books until somebody
found ways to exploit it and cost a lot
of money to taxpayers and of course
we're still smitten by the allure of
energy independence which is evermore
ambiguous and pointless and even
dangerous but still touted as a national
security need it is sold as something
more actually and has been since the 70s
a solve all too many of America's
problems not just in energy an energy
independence program run by benevolent
government will do everything from
create jobs to save our souls
indeed government energy policy has at
times taken on the
a secular religion we can be saved from
a myriad of ills by solar panels and
windmills on the right policy mix with
the right energy policies the angry seas
will become quiet the skies will clear
the unemployed will not only have good
jobs they will also be doing good we
shall face oil blackmail no more we
shall be redeemed it should be clear to
most people that any government program
expected to produce such wide-ranging
virtues is a set up for failure
we've been lured by panacea promises
imprisoned in our own narrative for the
last four decades and even now can't
seem to get out of it we find now that
even when Congress does it act agencies
and presidential orders guide the
visible hand to the energy cure-all
which of course is unlikely to be a cure
for anything at all thank you
Thank You dr. Grossman we now have some
time for some questions if you'd please
raise your hand we have two microphones
in the audience and when they come to
you please stand
they will also hold on to the microphone
so don't wrassle them or I'll come after
you please raise your hand and dr.
Grossman be happy I'm sure to answer
your questions thank you one thing that
I always think about is when President
Eisenhower sent a $0.10 a cubic tin says
a thousand cubic foot price on natural
gas that set the whole industry back for
25 years or more because he heard that
one of the senators received some slight
compensation for his vote I've known her
very righteous on a lot of things well
it was during Eisenhower's
administration that the Supreme Court
ruled in the Phillips case that the
federal Power Commission had the right
and duty presumably to regulate the
price of natural gas at the wellhead and
therefore it meant that essentially all
natural gas would be regulated at all
stages of its production and consumption
but the FPC was overwhelmed originally
when the when this case was presented
and they didn't see how they could
possibly come up with a price in the
next five years so to the extent that
any prices would be set often it would
be done by government Fiat by somebody
else directing them to do some make some
kind of price the thing about natural
gas pricing and natural gas regulation
is that it's been one of the most
contentious issues in Congress for the
past 450 years including in the
aftermath of that particular even before
that actually in the 1940s it was a
contentious issue within the FPC
in which there were two different views
that were vehemently expressed in
congressional hearings but by 1978 the
next natural major natural gas Act that
was passed in the Carter Administration
had 17 different prices for different
qualities and characteristics of natural
gas and the head of the FBC at the time
said there's no way this can be done in
any sensible way nevertheless it went on
someone who was involved in in the
debates around natural gas at the time
told me that one of the senators had
come out of a meeting and he said it was
like having a room full of Baptists and
Jews and expecting them all to become
Catholics energy economist Chris
Martenson describes what he refers to as
peak oil you have indicated through what
you've said earlier this evening that
the free market can respond to oil and
other fossil fuel shortages but if there
is in fact a physical limit on the
amount of recoverable fossil fuels what
would be the free market response to
that Peak Oil and do you believe there
is such a phenomenon as Peak Oil well to
answer the last part first there
certainly existentially oil will be
depleted it doesn't grow back after you
use it but I've seen no evidence that in
fact we're running out of oil the
evidence would be that the price would
continually rise in real terms
right now the price of oil is in real
terms lower than it was in 1979
if it keeps rising that means that in
fact it's becoming more scarce and then
and by the way this won't happen you
know some people have asked me well what
happens you know they'll turn the tap
and there'll be nothing that won't
happen
it will be the case that there will be
less of it around the price will have to
rise for those who want it and there
will be market incentives for
alternatives market incentives for
alternatives are much more likely to
lead to alternatives rather than
government programs that say we want
this we want that the the the there's a
kind of fantastic thinking that goes on
in all areas of government when it comes
to the promotion of new technologies and
the fact is that even now if the price
of oil stays where it is for a while if
the benefits for example for electric
cars are removed if the extra subsidies
for wind and solar are removed we'll
probably see those industries collapse
which we'd saw back in the 1970s 70s and
80s with solar thermal which and solar
hot water heating which was passed in
1978 with the thought that it would
produce two and a half million homes
with solar hot water heating by 1985 and
that in fact after that point it would
become the most obvious choice because
in fact we were running out of
alternatives natural gas and so on so
what would people use well the
technology would get better the cost
would go down we'd all be using solar
and in fact by 1985 more
solar systems were being removed from
houses than were being put into them the
government is not well-placed to create
a new viable commercial technology what
will do that is the fact that people
will be seeking alternatives and there
will be good reason for it
dr. grassman thank you so much for your
time and inspirational talk this evening
my question is going to go back to the
mandatory oil import quota that you
talked about towards the beginning of
your speech who exactly got the quarter
rents out of that quota and ruled to
whom that where the permits actually
issued thank you sir
well that that's an interesting question
because first of all the quota is there
they kept giving various exceptions so
that in fact it was supposed to limit I
can't remember what the amount was I
think 10% was all that could be imported
but the there were so many exceptions
and there were ways around it for
example a refinery was built a thing in
the Virgin Islands or in possibly in
Puerto Rico I can't remember now exactly
where but in any case it was look it
meant that that was no longer part of
the quota they could import oil from
somewhere but then they would export it
to the mainland and so it was no longer
imported oil there was the East Coast
objected to the fact because they were
depended more on imported oil and every
single time along the way they by the
time the quota was finally removed in
the early 1970s I think it was possible
limit imports to 10% we were already up
to 30% so to the extent that people were
it Claud brining her who was Secretary
of I think transportation in the Ford
administration I said that when he was
working for an oil company I think may
have been unical in in the 1950s he was
asked to look at that particular bill
and to see where there were loop
and he said he found hundreds of them
and everyone else who looked found
hundreds of them in exploited them your
long litany of idiocy coming from
Washington indicates that actually what
we should be having is separation of
state and energy then this this
conference would be a trade show and
would be plenty of anything well I you
know I've been asked a number of
occasions especially in the context of
my book does the government provide any
value added to the to energy in theory I
believe yes although when I presented
this people have always said it's not
going to happen well yes of course it's
not going to happen but if somebody asks
me I I referred to what I call the the
four eyes but for one of those eyes the
four eyes are information ideas
institutions and infrastructure but the
institutions are the most important one
institutions were a real barrier and I
mentioned the rules about two different
kinds of arrangements for contractual
arrangements for oil fields two of them
were outlawed in in Texas so they had to
go to proration which was definitely an
inferior means of utilizing the field
right now when people talk about smart
smart metering and a smart grid it's not
going to happen easily because the grid
is under the jurisdiction of like well
it depends where you are but sometimes
as many as five different agencies in of
three different levels of government so
in theory they could make
cause that and rules that would
facilitate new technologies facilitate
new ideas and facilitate the
opportunities for consumers whether
they'll do it I don't think so
it doesn't play near it doesn't play
very well too for a politician to get up
and say well you know we couldn't
improve the institutions of energy and
someone else gets up and says energy
independence now and who gets the
applause well not the first guy but then
again the first guy doesn't exist except
for people like me and I don't run for
office nor do I intend to
you mentioned a couple of items of
regulation which I understand have since
been repealed one of the well head
regulation on natural gas and the other
is the prohibition of the use of natural
gas and electric generation yes so have
there been any benefits from the
sweeping away of that right oh
absolutely
absolutely I mean now they as I said
they the the best thing the government
has generally done is reversed what the
government had previously done the the
in the ban on on natural gas and oil
fired electric generation was repealed
in 1987 when it was clear that the
repeal of price controls on natural gas
was actually leading to a lot of natural
gas and so the that was one thing that
was repealed that particular rule and of
course much of electric generation since
that time has been natural gas-fired and
we have more natural gas now than
possibly ever but I it is the case that
they that some of these some things have
been changed some things rules have been
changed the natural gas rules though
were one of the hardest ones to change
the price and allocation controls on oil
were swept away the second day I believe
of the Reagan administration he said he
was going to do it and he did it and in
fact everybody there were all these
editorials and arguments and people
saying this is going to be a catastrophe
for consumers I think Howard Metzenbaum
a senator who was known for his support
of consumer groups said this
administration will rue the day that it
did this and of course everybody
predicted the price would go up I spoke
to Murray Wheaton the late Murray Whedon
bum who would
and the chairman of the Economic
Advisers under Reagan and he said he
went over to the Department of Energy to
deal with help the new energy secretary
deal with the press over this and he
said that he made the comment that he
didn't think prices would go up very
much maybe not at all and he said he was
practically laughed off the stage well
they went down and I went down
continually through the 1980s now
natural gas though had a lot more
trouble it was not fully released from
all of those price regulations until
1990 and I may have been 89 but it was
the HW Bush administration and it came
at least 11 years after the the natural
gas act of Carter in 78 we have time for
one more question right energy
independence it's I've heard it often
touted by both sides of the political
spectrum like with Mike with Palin
touting drilling in Alaska and then with
liberals citing solar or wind energy now
I was wondering are both sides operating
under a assumption that energy
independence is necessarily good yes and
what are the like in sentence or two why
do you think that that's necessarily bad
why energy independence necessarily bad
well first of all I don't know what
anybody means when they say it if they
mean complete autarky in other words
complete separation from all energy
markets other than our own we actually
will be less secure will have higher
prices and will be it will would be a a
well as a friend of mine said what if
anybody said asks you why don't we have
energy independence just tell them that
they managed it in Ceausescu's Romania
and anyone familiar with what happened
in that particular instant instance
would not be recommending
as a cure-all for the United States but
energy independence is touted by
everybody and I believe it's because
they have a mistaken notion about what
the energy problem is and what it stems
from and that until we get a change in
the narrative about what happened in the
past and therefore what needs to be what
kinds of problems actually exist that
we're always going to have this kind of
topping of energy and dependency from
your right from left and right I was at
a conference in Texas the person from
the Texas Railroad Commission got up and
he excoriated the book the obama excuse
me the obama administration because he
was a republican and he said that it was
preventing us from having energy
independence and i was there with a
friend of mine and he looked at me and
we were both shaking our heads you know
this this is always going to come up
with with that kind of mentality well he
was followed by four people one
representing Texas wind another one
representing a program two for carbon
capture and sequestration another one
solar and so on well what's the first
thing out of their mouths energy
independence and we'll only get it if we
start head you know if we have as I
sometimes say a windmill on every house
and two solar panels on every garage and
that why that is unfortunately a debate
that doesn't get back to square one I'm
giving a talking in Washington on
December 5th which essentially is that
bipartisanship on energy has led us to
some of the worst kinds of energy
legislature
and that we what we really need to do is
to get back to understanding what has
actually happened over the past 40 years
and until we do we're still going to be
spinning our wheels in some sense and
doing the same kind of thing over and
over again I mean President Obama's
energy program with his electric cars
and all that stuff is it zack mirror of
what was going on in the 70s and just
about every time since then especially
any time there's a price spike or a cry
of energy crisis energy crisis is one of
those buzzwords that also doesn't mean
anything and but leads to a kind of
panic in Congress but my opening thing
my opening line while meant to be a
reflection of a great speech was in fact
the way energy policy was made then and
it has generally been made that it comes
out of crises and it's crisis driven and
it is often therefore incoherent because
well as one senator said in the late 70s
we're moving forward on this but we
don't know what we're doing and I
thought that should be sort of something
that they should put up on the on the
floor of the of both houses of Congress
as the motto especially when they're
negotiating energy issues because you
know I I have a little bit I do a lot of
blinking and I have this minor
neurological problem that I'm told is
hereditary but I believe it came from
reading the Congressional Record on
energy debates
Thank You dr. Grossman dr. Grossman will
be signing his book all hock it for him
it was named the energy book of the year
by power line blog and its name it's
entitled US energy policy and the
pursuit of failure he'll be signing it
just down here by the state by the two
different stairways on this floor right
after this and students you're reminded
to please use the stairway on the left
here as you exit thank you very much